afin de préserver son anonymat nous
l'appellerons paul ce père de famille de
54 ans décédé à l'hôpital
en janvier dernier paul est opérée d'un
ulcère à l'estomac par un chirurgien du
centre hospitalier de versoix une
opération bénigne selon les spécialistes
sauf qu'après l'opération la santé du
quinquagénaire va se dégrader
un nouveau chirurgien opère paul par
deux fois mais sans pouvoir le sauver
y at il eu faute médicale du premier
chirurgien un de ses anciens confrères
auteur d'un essai sur les dérives de
l'hôpital public est en tout cas très
critique
on a de la compétence relative
oui hétérogène du praticien
comment peut-on et laisser les
praticiens eux opérer sa radio acculé
d'urgence alors qu'ils parlent pas
français alors que leurs compétences
faut pas été prouvée les vidéos généraux
de france et de navarre
ça devient compliqué ça devient
compliqué est un scandale la famille de
paul a porté plainte contre le premier
chirurgien qui a opéré et a porté
plainte également contre l'hôpital de
nevers dans un communiqué celui ci
indique que le praticien mise en cause
embauché en juillet 2015 n'intervient
plus depuis mars 2016 la faire confiait
la justice a été transmise à l'ordre des
médecins de la nièvre qui doit aussi se
pencher sur la mort prématurée d'un père
de famille de 54 ans